[Applause]
check out with your Chicago here hey I
think she was just adamant about coming
in support and I just said uh you can
miss one day at school and you know come
to a game and I'm glad I did it was take
your daughter to work day that DeMar
DeRozan will never forget
if he steps the wrong way or something
visit to Florida State basketball
Patrick said I was down for whatever
coach Hamilton the Chicago Bull star's
daughter Dr helping dad play defense
from the stands
underrated passer doing a nice job and I
don't know if you saw but your daughter
Dr
she was making an impact on the free
throw line yeah anytime the Toronto
Raptors were at the free throw line the
total number of everyone could hear the
screams coming from Dr Who was sitting
behind the Raptor's basket life is
really good for him right now he's in a
good you know it's crazy my daughter
called me the other day
um when she was getting out of school
and she was just you know she just said
dad can I can I come to the Toronto game
[Applause]
and it wasn't long before the announcers
caught on that is the daughter of
DeMar DeRozan
and here's the voice you're hearing when
Raptors shoot she's screaming
[Applause]
he'd be not as tight as ESPN pointed out
Dr strategy was a slam dunk for the
Raptors Wednesday's game was their worst
free throw shooting performance of the
season they missed 16 free throws a
20-point Advantage this guy thinks he
can do more and the scoreboard speaks
for itself Chicago nabbed a four-point
victory over Toronto I think she was
just adamant about coming in support and
I just said uh you can miss one day at
school and you know come to a game and
I'm glad I did um I'll order some money
for sure
the third and fourth periods well moving
forward this season at least the other
teams can rest easy
uh no she got to go back to school
said very much still the backbone
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]